good morning believe nation today's
messages have passion over to you film
night if you're gonna be an entrepreneur
you better be prepared for long hours on
a lot of dark moments and I guess that's
one thing that's shown in the book and I
think you know you really have to have a
passion about it and you have to have a
reason to succeed you can't it isn't to
be just something that you want to be
that you have to have a niche and a
passion you need those two things so
having passion is a topic we've talked
about a lot on this channel it's a
consistent theme that comes up with
success in any field you have to have
passion for what you're doing what I
liked about this message it was a little
bit different was when he said you have
to have a reason to succeed where I
think a lot of people don't have a
strong enough reason they don't have a
strong enough why they have a goal you
know what you want to get you know what
the outcome is but you don't have a
strong enough reason why that goal is so
important and so that's why money itself
is the terrible goal that's why if
you're only certain the business because
you want to make a lot of money or you
want to buy that car or go on that trip
or buy that house or whatever it is it's
why you won't succeed that's why you
won't get the money because you don't
have a strong enough reason why and so
for me if I think about it on an
emotional level why do I love helping
entrepreneurs on an emotion level for me
it's I love feeling like I'm having an
impact I love helping people
I love believing in people I love seeing
the spark that comes alive
I love taking somebody who's here and
then recognizing that they could be way
up here and helping them get along that
path it just makes me feel insanely good
and it's a drug that I'm addicted to I
love
believing in people and so I do that
through my YouTube channel to with you
guys and the comments that you guys
leave every day fuels me because I know
that I'm having that impact that's the
emotional level on the intellectual
level for me I feel like entrepreneurs
will solve all the major problems of the
world I don't think it's gonna be the
government's and the politicians or the
big corporations I think it's gonna be
the entrepreneurs who solve all their
major
of this world from health to poverty to
not having Wars right space travel like
all of the major things that we want to
get done is gonna be from entrepreneurs
on that intellectual level I want to
have that big impact I want to know that
I'm here helping a billion entrepreneurs
making an impact they're off doing their
thing to go make that world a better
place and so on an emotional and
intellectual level that's why I do what
I do my goal may be to get the billion
entrepreneurs or my next immediate goal
maybe five hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers or a million YouTube
subscribers that's great but it's not
why I'm doing it and so you need to
connect your Y with the actions in your
business if you don't have a strong Y
then you need to find one or go do
something else where you have a good one
so the question today today is what is
your why why do you do what you do why
is it so imperative that this succeeds
and you continue on your path even if
you weren't even making any money doing
it you're gonna keep going because of
this why what is that
leaving the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion finally I want to
give a quick shout-out to Stefan or
Stefan warum thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book really really
really deeply means a lot to me
those are you watching you want your
chance at a shout out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your seats so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press
you